quelque part dans le labyrinthe des
archives nationales des centaines de
cartons qui contiennent les archives
privées de simone veil décidé depuis mon
adolescence à être avocat pour des
raisons plus ou moins bonnes d'ailleurs
l'expérience de la déportation n'a fait
que confirmer cette intention
espérant alors pouvoir faire quelque
chose pour les condamnés ou anciens
condamnés et victimes de leur passé de
leur milieu et de leur misère
elle va se soucier de ce qu'on peut
encore offrir à cette autre pour qu'ils
gardent une dignité pour qu'ils puissent
se relever et là on l'a encore là la
question de la résilience qui est si
central dans sa vie et qui en fait sa
propre résidence qu'elle raconte par ces
actes politiques est omniprésente
comment on fait pour que l'autre se
relève pour qu'il puisse encore être
simone veil mémoire d'une immortel c'est
sur public sénat
[Musique]